BRIAN: NO WORDS IN THAT PROMO,
BUT IT SAID A LOT.
[LAUGHTER]
I’M HOPING MARK MEADOWS WILL SAY
A FEW WORDS, MAYBE THE MVP OF
THAT CURRENT WHITE HOUSE AND
CURRENTLY ONE OF THE FEW WITHOUT
THE CORONAVIRUS.
FIRST OFF, ON THE PRESIDENT,
MARK MEADOWS, THE WORD IS GOING
INTO TODAY HE HAD NO COVID-19
SYMPTOMS.
WHAT ABOUT HIM, WHAT ABOUT YOU?
>> YEAH, HE’S DOING REAL WELL.
WE ACTUALLY SPENT SOME TIME
TOGETHER YESTERDAY WORKING VERY
HARD FROM THE RESIDENCE, AND I
CAN TELL YOU THAT HE’S FULLY
ENGAGED AND FEELING GREAT.
YOU KNOW, HIS HEART CONTINUES TO
GO OUT TO THE MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS WHO HAVE STRUGGLED
WITH THIS VIRUS.
HAVING NOT ONLY GOTTEN IT, BUT
HAVING GOTTEN TREATMENT FROM THE
GREAT FOLKS AT WALTER REED, I
CONTINUE TO TEST NEGATIVE, BUT
AT THE SAME TIME WE KNOW THIS
VIRUS WILL, HAS A WAY OF TO HAVE
REACHING OUT AND GETTING PEOPLE
WHEN THEY LEAST EXPECT IT.
SO THE PRESIDENT IS, HAS ALREADY
BEEN ON THE PHONE THIS MORNING
TALKING TO SECRETARY MNUCHIN.
THE SECRETARY AND I HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT WHAT WE COULD DO
WITH STAND-ALONE BILLS TO HELP
AIRLINES, SMALL BUSINESSES AND
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WITH
STIMULUS CHECKS.
SO, HOPEFULLY, WEBBING CONVINCE
SPEAKER PELOSI -- WE CAN
CONVINCE SPEAKER PELOSI TO DO
SOMETHING ON A STAND-ALONE
BASIS.
STEVE: NANCY PELOSI WAS
APPARENTLY ON A PHONE CALL
YESTERDAY, AND THERE’S A QUOTE
FROM BLOOMBERG NEWS THAT SAYS
PELOSI EARLIER TOLD HOUSE
DEMOCRATS ON A CONFERENCE CALL
THAT TRUMP’S THINKING MIGHT BE
AFFECTED BY THE STEROIDS HE’S
TAKEN TO TREAT HIS CORONAVIRUS
INFECTION ACCORDING TO A
LAWMAKER ON THE CALL.
SO, MARK, NANCY PELOSI IS
SUGGESTING THAT THE PRESIDENT IS
MAKING SOME CRAZY DECISIONS.
HE’S, IT’S LIKE ROID RAGE.
>> WELL, SPEAKER PELOSI
CONTINUES TO THROW OUT ALL KINDS
OF REASONS FOR THE FAILURE ON
THE NEGOTIATION OTHER THAN
LOOKING IN THE MIRROR, BECAUSE
WE KNOW THAT CONSISTENTLY SHE’S
BEEN AT THE 2.2-2.4 TRILLION
DEPENDING ON WHAT DAY YOU TALK
TO HER.
SHE’S FAILED TO BUDGE.
SHE’S NOT NEGOTIATING IN GOOD
FAITH, AND A NUMBER OF US
YESTERDAY WERE ON A CALL WITH
THE PRESIDENT AS WE LOOKED AT
THE PROGRESS THAT HAD BEEN MADE
OR, I MIGHT SAY, THAT HAD NOT
BEEN MADE, AND THE PRESIDENT
FELT LIKE IT WAS BETTER TO BE
TRANSPARENT WITH THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND THE PROGNOSIS OF
WHETHER WE WOULD BE ABLE TO GET
IT.
HE’S STILL FULLY ENGAGED.
I WILL SAY THIS, SECRETARY
MNUCHIN AND THE PRESIDENT HAVE
OFFERED $1.6 TRILLION, WILLING
TO LOOK AT, THEY WERE WILLING TO
LOOK AT A LITTLE BIT MORE THAN
THAT BECAUSE THEY HAD GIVEN
MONEY FOR SCHOOLS.
THEY HAD GIVEN MONEY FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES, MONEY FOR CHILDCARE,
MONEY REALLY FOR THE AIR ALINES
AND A NUMBER OF -- AIRLINES AND
A NUMBER OF THE OTHER PLACES
THAT ARE HURTING RIGHT NOW.
AND SHE CONTINUES TO SAY THAT
IT’S NOT ENOUGH.
SO SHE’D RATHER SPEND ZERO THAN
$1.6 TRILLION, AND I DON’T KNOW
THAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WILL
ACCEPT THAT.
AINSLEY: I KNOW THAT STEPHEN
MILLER TESTED POSITIVE, HE’S A
SPEECH WRITER AND ONE OF TRUMP’S
SENIOR ADVISERS.
WHAT PRECAUTIONS IS THE WHITE
HOUSE PUTTING IN PLACE NOW?
>> YEAH.
WE’VE ACTUALLY HAD A NUMBER OF
PRECAUTIONS IN PLACE.
OBVIOUSLY, WITH STEPHEN MILLER,
WE KNEW THAT HE HAD A POTENTIAL
EXPOSURE.
HE’S ACTUALLY BEEN WORKING FROM
HOME SINCE THAT, THAT TIME.
WE HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN TESTING
HIM EACH AND EVERY DAY TO MAKE
SURE THAT WHENN HE TURNED
POSITIVE, WE WOULD KNOW THAT
JUST BECAUSE HE HAD VERY CLOSE
CONTACT WITH HOPE HICKS.
AND SO AS THE NEWS CAME OUT
YESTERDAY, WE KIND OF HAD
ANTICIPATED THAT.
THE CONTACT TRACING FOR HIM WAS
REALLY ZERO BECAUSE HE HADN’T
BEEN IN CONTACT WITH ANYBODY IN
THE WEST WING.
WE’VE ACTUALLY ALSO DONE SOME
ADDITIONAL PROTOCOLS IN
MATERIALS OF CORDONING OFF
DIFFERENT WORKING GROUPS TO TRY
TO NOT TO ONLY STOP IT, BUT ALSO
UNDERSTAND HOW WE CAN PUT IN
ADDITIONAL PROTOCOLS TO MAKE
SURE PEOPLE ARE SAFE.
BRIAN: MARK, AS YOU KNOW, WHEN
YOU COME OUT OF BUSINESS HOURS
WITH THE TWEET THAT THE
PRESIDENT CAME OUT WITH, IT
TANKED THE MARKET.
AND THIS AN HOUR BEFORE THE FED
CHAIR JEROME POWELL SAYS, HE
WARNED FAILING TO INJECT MORE
FEDERAL HELP INTO THE ECONOMY
WOULD RISK WEAKENING THE TENUOUS
RECOVERY.
OUR COUNTRY NEEDS STIMULUS
CHECKS.
HAVING SAID THAT, HE’S NOT
SAYING REPUBLICANS OR DEMOCRATS.
IT’S TO THE PRESIDENT’S
ADVANTAGE AND THE COUNTRY’S NEED
TO GET SOMETHING IN THERE.
WHY CAN’T YOU WORK SOMETHING OUT
BEING THAT STEVE MNUCHIN HAD TWO
LONG MEETINGS YESTERDAY?
DID HE COME BACK, THROW UP HIS
HANDS AND ASK THE PRESIDENT, DO
WE ME A FAVOR, TWEET?
COULD YOU BRING US INSIDE THAT
PROCESS?
>> I THINK I WAS SHARING THAT WE
ACTUALLY HAD A PHONE CALL IN.
WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS THAT DON’T LEAD
ANYWHERE, BRIAN, AND WHEN YOU DO
THAT, WE WERE ON WITH LEADER
McCARTHY, LEADER McCONNELL,
THE PRESIDENT, MYSELF.
AND AS WE WERE TALKING ABOUT THE
PROGRESS THERE, THE NUMBERS THEY
WERE TALKING ABOUT ARE JUST
INCREDIBLY HIGH IN TERMS OF
BAILOUTS FOR STATES, BLUE-RUN
STATES.
THE NUMBERS THEY’RE SUGGESTING
ARE MUCH HIGHER THAN WHAT THE
WILL AND THE NEED IS.
ADDITIONALLY ARE, WHEN WE LOOK
AT -- THIS WAS A BIPARTISAN
PROPOSAL PUT OUT BY THE PROCESS
OFFERS.
ALMOST AT EVERY TURN THE
PROPOSAL THAT THE PRESIDENT PUT
FORTH WAS ACTUALLY BETTER THAN
THAT PROPOSAL.
YOU KNOW, THERE COMES A POINT
WHERE YOU UNDERSTAND THAT THE
OTHER SIDE IS JUST PLAYING
POLITICS.
THE REAL THING IS SPEAKER PELOSI
DIDN’T WANT THOSE CHECKS TO GO
OUT TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
BEFORE NOVEMBER 3RD.
SHE FELT LIKE IT WOULD HELP THE
PRESIDENT, AND SO SHE’S BEEN
NEGOTIATING IN THAT MANNER.
AND SO, YOU KNOW, WE’RE STILL
WILLING TO BE ENGAGED, BUT I’M
NOT OPTIMISTIC FOR A
COMPREHENSIVE DEAL.
I AM OPTIMISTIC THAT THERE’S
ABOUT TEN THINGS THAT WE CAN TO
ON A PIECEMEAL BASIS IF THE
SPEAK E ORER WILLING TO PUT IT
BEFORE HER MEMBERS.
STEVE: ONE OF THE OTHER TWEETS
FROM THE PRESIDENT, I THINK IT
WAS IN THE 6 OR 7:00 HOUR,
MR. MEADOWS, WAS THE PRESIDENT
ANNOUNCED THAT THE DECLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS FROM MR. BRENNAN,
FORMERLY AT THE CIA, AND OTHERS
HAD BEEN RELEASED LAST NIGHT.
AND ESSENTIALLY WHAT IT LOOKS
LIKE, THE NOTE FROM CIA DIRECTOR
BRENNAN LOOKS LIKE HILLARY
CLINTON AND THEIR CAMPAIGN
ORDERED A CAMPAIGN PLAN TO STIR
UP A SCANDAL BY LINKING TRUMP TO
RUSSIA IN 2016 TO DEFLECT FROM
HER PRIVATE E-MAIL SERVER THAT
THE, YOU KNOW, EVERYBODY WAS A
AFRAID WAS NOT SECURE ENOUGH.
THIS GOES BACK TO YOUR DAYS IN
CONGRESS.
NOBODY KNOWS MORE ABOUT THIS
THAN YOU.
THIS IS NOT SURPRISING.
>> WELL, IT’S NOT SURPRISING TO
ME, BUT IT IS SURPRISING TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WHEN YOU SEE BRENNAN’S NOTES,
AND ONE OF THE THINGS HE PUTS IN
THERE IS TO VILIFY DONALD TRUMP.
I MEAN, WHEN YOU LOOK AT A
COORDINATED EFFORT AND NOW YOU
SEE IT IN HIS OWN HANDWRITING,
WHY IS THIS JUST NOW COMING OUT
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE?
WHY AFTER $45 MILLION DID
MUELLER NOT PUT ANY OF THIS IN
HIS REPORT TO SAY THERE COULD
HAVE BEEN A DIFFERENT NARRATIVE?
THERE ARE MORE DOCUMENTS TO
COME.
THE PRESIDENT WANTS TRANSPARENCY
ON ALL OF THIS ANDING HOPEFULLY,
WE’LL SEE DOCUMENTS --
BRIAN: WHAT DID DAN COATS DO FOR
TWO OR THREE YEARS?
>> OBVIOUSLY, DAN COATS DID NOT
ALLOW THESE DOCUMENTS TO COME
OUT.
I WANT TO APPLAUD DIRECTOR
RATCLIFFE AND HIS WILLINGNESS
AND DIRECTOR GRENELL BEFORE HIM
IN TERMS OF TRYING TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THE TRUTH.
THE PRESIDENT’S BEEN SAYING IT
FROM DAY ONE, NOW ALL OF A
SUDDEN WE HAVE THE DOCUMENTS TO
SUPPORT HIM.
AINSLEY: THE ONLY PROBLEM IS THE
OTHER NETWORKS ARE NOT COVERING
IT, NBC, ABC, CBS DIDN’T COVER
IT ON THEIR NIGHTLY --
>> WELL, THAT’S NOT A SURPRISE.
IOWANS IT IS SUCH A BIG STORY
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC NEEDS TO
KNOW THOUGH.